[Musik]
drei euro hat es gekostet dieses schmale
büchlein in seiner originalversion
eingeschlagen hat das in frankreich wie
eine bombe innerhalb von drei monaten
wurden davon eine million exemplare
verkauft und das trotz einem völlig
unzeitgemäßen titel die niveau empört
euch
geschrieben hat es stefan ssl war
résistance kämpfer im zweiten weltkrieg
diplomaten algerien den vietnam und
später frankreichs botschafter bei der
uno jetzt ist er 94 empört und engagiert
sich über die ungleiche verteilung des
reichtums über die migrationspolitik
über den umgang israels mit den
palästinensern eine komplexe welt so der
jahrhundert zeuge slr fordert komplexe
strategien juri steiner hat mit ihm
dieses jahr ein gespräch geführt
sie sind 93 jahre alt bald 94 sie
beschäftigen sich mit sehr schweren
großen themen wie entwicklungshilfe
demokratie menschenrechte und sie sind
ein jugendidol in frankreich haben sie
mit ihrem letzten buch fast eine million
auflage gemacht dass haben popstars mit
ihren platten wie erklären sie sich
diese resonanz ist wirklich für mich die
richtige frage als wie dieses büchlein
was wir auf französisch lg evo und auf
deutsch empört euch übersetzt haben
dachten wir dass wir vielleicht 8.000
10.000 franzosen interessieren franzosen
denn es stimmt ja auch ist es kommt es
nimmt seinen anfang an dem widerstand in
frankreich während der kriegszeit
während des vichy regimes und das
interessiert natürlich franzosen und
auch nur allzu franzosen wie ich und
plötzlich ist das buch gerade bei den
jungen gut angekommen
weil es ihnen gesagt hat sie müssen sich
empören
denn was hier passiert was ihre
regierungen hier treiben ihre
französische regierung hier treibt das
könnt ihr nicht akzeptieren der müsst
ihr euch dagegen gegen und sie möchte
euch empören und merkwürdigerweise hat
das nicht nur die franzosen sondern auch
mehrere europäische länder und sogar die
nordafrikanischen länder irgendwie
angegangen
also es muss schon etwas dahinter stehen
ich habe mich natürlich die frage
gestellt warum hat das einen solchen
erfolg
sie sagten eben eine million 1 2
millionen 200.000 exemplare auf
französisch und auftritt auch schon über
400.000 also es bedeutet dass dieses
problem diese frage
diese frage an unsere moderne
gesellschaft eine wichtige richtige
frage ist über die man gut nachdenken
kann
natürlich ist dieses kleine buch nur ein
aufruf ihr müsst euch empören
es genügt natürlich nicht man muss
weiter nachdenken ja was tun wir denn
wenn man sich empört hat dazu kam dann
ein zweites kleines buch das haben wir
gelernt engagiert euch also es ist schon
ein fortschritt in der richtung man darf
sich nicht nur empören man muss man muss
tätig werden und sich also engagiert
aber merkwürdigerweise traf dieses
büchlein einen punkt unserer
weltgeschichte wo eben in vielen der
die frage hoch gab wo gehen wir denn hin
was passiert mitteln sind wir in der
richtigen richtung oder nicht müssen wir
uns völlig verändern oder nicht und
dafür war dieses kleine buch ein
interessanter anrufe wenn man auch ihre
biografie liest die sie 1995 schon
geschrieben haben und k4 sehr intensives
leben zurückschauen und wenn man nur
schon merkt was sie alles erlebt haben
vor ihrem dreißigsten geburtstag sie
waren hier in berlin geboren sie wurden
dann franzosen in frankreich die
schulung besucht sie waren in einer sehr
literarisch kultur ihren intellektuellen
familie eingebettet haben alle
avantgardistischen künstler bekannt und
so weiter und so fort wie schlagen sie
den bogen über dieses ganze jahrhundert
ins 21 jahrhundert über ihre eigene
biografie wann haben sie sich zum ersten
mal empörend ich würde sagen meine
generation also 1917 geboren
das jahr der russischen region der
oktoberrevolution und zwar bin ich im
oktober 1917 geburt also eine generation
die hat vor allem etwas erlebt was etwas
ganz unwahrscheinlich einen zweiten
weltkrieg als ich geboren da war gerade
der erste wert gewann bar zu ende und
man sagt sich jetzt haben wir die
möglichkeit die liegeflächen sind
völkerbund jetzt kommt frieden und der
frieden geht es schlecht aus und dann
kam eben die fürchten die zweite
weltkrieg nicht ein weltkrieg wie ein
anderer
ein krieg in dem eine nation ein volk
das deutsche volk sich jo hat überreden
lassen von einem fürchterlichen kerl dem
hitler dass es krieg reich geworden ist
wunder
sie kreist vier jahre lang und dann
völlig zerstört und damit kamen
wenigstens zwei große erscheinungen
auschwitz also die schuhe den juden
gegenüber und hiroshima plötzlich die
kernwaffe also wenn man das überlebt wie
er sich überlebt habe sie sagten gerade
als 30 jahre er nicht mal als 25 27
jährige
das bringt eine natur der natürlich dazu
man empfiehlt empfindet wird sich eine
verantwortung und mein gefühl als ich
aus dem krieg heraus kam war ich will
jetzt nicht mehr philosophie lehrern das
wollte ich vorher nämlich nein ich will
mich jetzt für mitarbeiter aller länder
aller staaten um eine neue möglichkeit
des friedens und der entwicklung wir
waren sehr sehr ehrgeizig
wir sagten uns unsere generation muss
etwas ganz neues aufbauen und als wir
anfingen etwas aufzubauen also zum
beispiel saß ich in new york in den drei
jahren wo man die allgemeinen erklärung
für menschenrechte ab arbeitete da saß
ich mit eleanor roosevelt und mit wenig
essen zusammen und wir sagten uns dass
ich nie tun ist überhaupt weltweit
gültig sogar wir waren glücklich das
casa sagte nein nicht allgemeine den
universal also für einen jungen mann der
aus dem kz herausgekommen war war es
eine sehr ehrgeizige ein sehr
ehrgeiziger moment und ich sagte mir
jetzt muss ich mein überleben dem widmen
was meine kameraden die verloren sind
nicht mehr tun können das ist jetzt
meine verantwortung so sieht es für mich
aus in den nächsten jahren nach
dem weg wir müssen jetzt eine neue welt
bauen
haben sie sie gebaut diese neue welt das
ist für mich die wichtige frage was
haben wir denn geleistet haben wir alles
viel geleistet oder vielleicht nicht
alles viel geleistet ich würde sagen was
wir am schlechtesten getan haben ist
kriege endgültig unmöglich zu machen
das war der erste der erst die erste
aufgabe von den vereinten nationen nicht
nie mehr einen krieg na ja wir haben
keinen dritten weltkrieg gehabt es schon
etwas aber kriege hat es immer wieder
gegeben und zwar sogar in europa kriege
in jugoslawien kriege hier und da also
das war nicht ein großer großes wort
kommen aber menschenrechte das ist
vielleicht etwas besseres natürlich sind
die menschenrechte für alle leute noch
nicht voll gewerbe gefertigt
aber immerhin gibt es große fortschritte
in vielen ländern der welt nicht nur in
europa sondern auch in lateinamerika in
sogar in asien auch in einigen
afrikanischen ländern
also man muss schon sagen diese anhieb
menschenrecht wir müssen jetzt das
wichtig zu sein
naja es ist weit entfernt noch das
programm ist noch nicht aus habe das
programm steht da und es gibt jetzt in
allen staaten der welt bei allen völkern
der welt gibt es gruppen die sich für
menschenrechte eingehen amnestie fn.de
jungen rights watch also da ist schon
ein gewisser fortschritt ungenügend denn
die regierungen sind noch nicht so weit
dass sie diese menschenrechte wirklich
überall befürworten aber es gibt es gut
dass mehr europa
wir haben immerhin europa aufgebaut wenn
auch unsere liebe schweiz immer noch
nicht in der union ist aber sie sitzt im
europarat und wir brauchen sie sie gibt
uns große beispiel für richtige
demokratie also das aufbauen von europa
ist eine der leistungen meiner
generation
was haben wir sonst noch geschafft und
kolonisierung es war auch nicht leicht
man konnte sich sagen warum sollten denn
die franzosen aus algerien weg sie sind
doch mächtiger als die unglücklichen
algier
nein aber die gerade der druck von den
französischen bürgern hat dazu geführt
die haben schließlich gesagt nein nein
wir kennen nicht mehr kolonialmächte
werden die engländer haben es schnell
gemacht die portugiesen etwas später sie
sprachen ja auch also dass die
dekolonisierung ist immerhin man kann
ihn schon als einen großen fortschritt
in unserer welt geschichte zum beispiel
waren es 54 mitglied nationen die die
allgemeine erklärung der menschenrechte
abgefertigt haben
heute sind wir 193 naja ist das ein
großer fortschritt
man kann darüber nachdenken aus
wenigstens eine große veränderung was
noch naja immerhin die phase berliner
mauer wir sitzen hier zusammen in berlin
ein schicksals statt wie es keine
anderen der welt gibt und die mauer ist
flüssig gefahren und gorbatschow ist
gekommen sowjetunion ist verschwunden
jetzt haben wir russland und anderen
ländern
das ist doch auch und kann es schon als
ein fortschritt empfinden
dazu natürlich die apartheid in
südafrika kommt auch dazu
und jetzt das internationale finale
tribunal wie macht man das auf deutsch
geld tun
hagen der chempark ich war also
fortschritte schon
trotzdem empfinden wir jetzt dass die
letzten zehn jahre die ersten zehn
jahren des einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
rückschritte gekannt hat und dass es
darum wichtig ist dass wir uns jetzt
empören so dass diese fortschritte des
zwanzigsten jahrhundert in weitere
schritte noch wichtigere straftritte im
21 jahrhundert gehen
sie holen natürlich hier so eine innere
motivation der jugend ab sich zu
empörung ist etwas was jede jugend
generation gerne tut weil man sich
auflehnen kann weil man sich selber
findet auch in dieser empörung drin die
natürlich auch etwas destruktives
destruktives potenzial mit beinhaltet
und glauben sie nicht dass sie auch ein
bisschen gezündelt haben mit ihrem werk
sie haben ganz recht dass ist wird nicht
die gefahr dieses kurzen buches wenn man
es nur ansieht als einsendung einer
entzündung dann kann es gefährlich
werden
leute können sich ja ich empöre mich
darüber dass es bei bei mir zu viele
afrikaner gibt das empört mich und ich
möchte sie raus treiben oder es gibt all
diese songs was tun die hier die schon
job weg gehen das wäre auch eine
empörung aber natürlich meiner meinung
nach die ganz falsche empörung wie macht
man denn den unterschied zwischen einer
guten und einer schlechten empörung
das beste ist mein kleines buch wirklich
zum linie sind nicht nur den titel
sondern auch gleich am anfang die
grundwerte deren zerstörung uns empören
aber das ist nicht so leicht zu
verstehen die gefahr besteht daher haben
wir auch das gefühl man muss jetzt
weiter
und wir haben ja ein zweites buch jetzt
das haben wir gelernt engagiert euch
setzt euch ein
denn wenn man sich nur empöre und dann
nichts daraus bringt dann geht es
natürlich nicht weiter ich möchte
vielleicht nochmals kurz den bogen
schlagen weil es einen sehr wichtigen
und auch sehr poetischen satz gibt da ja
wie ein programm auch ein bisschen über
ihrem leben steht nämlich krise es ist
resistent französisch einsatz der
resistance
sie kennen die deutsche übersetzung
dieses satzes besser
welche bedeutung hat dieser satz der
résistance gestern gehabt und welchen
sinn hat er heute also da müssen wir
wirklich darüber nachdenken diese zwei
sätze die sich den schwanz in den mund
nehmen
ich war also was ist das denn was ist
den widerstand und was ist neues
schaffen wie man es auf deutsch
übersetzt hat es bedeutet für mich nur
ein rückblick wir brauchen manchmal
richtige rückblicke ein rückblick auf
die zeit in der wir keine macht- hatten
in der wir von der wehrmacht überzogen
wurden und dennoch sagten wir müssen
jetzt widerstand leisten und dass dieser
widerstand bedeutet dass wir etwas neues
schaffen eine demokratie wollten
geschaffen der vision regierung entgegen
im neuen und wir wussten auch dass
dieses schatten immer mit einem
widerstand zu tun haben
es war eine erinnerung und wir wollten
der jungen französischen generation
sagen ihr müsst verstehen dass wir was
schaffen wollt dann müsst ihr es gegen
einen widerstand schaffen
aber welche widerstand und welches
schaffen
das ist natürlich etwas ganz anderes
heutzutage und das zu verstehen wo gegen
müssen wir heute widerstand leisten
dazu gehört eben ein richtiges lesen von
diesem uhr und von vielen anderen
büchern
ich sage immer meinen liedern wenn sie
ungenügend an meinung kein buch in die
neben sich empfinden sage ich ihnen ja
jetzt müssen die richtigen bücher lesen
ich bin kein soziologe
ich bin auch kein philosoph mehr bitte
lesen sie doch edgar morava der weg oder
lesen sieglose flip chip oder am 18
es gibt ja leute die den weg weisen
meine aufgabe ist nur sie dazu zu
bringen dass sie sich erst mal die frage
stellen warum geht es mir nicht recht
warum bin ich hier bin ich nicht
zufrieden also ich muss mich schon
empören und dann anzufangen zu verstehen
welches sind denn heutzutage die neuen
gründe sich zu empören
wir haben nicht mehr hitler und nicht
mehr stalin und auch nicht mehr
algerienkrieg oder so wir brauchen wir
müssen nachsehen was sind denn die neuen
empörungen für uns und darüber auch nur
nachzudenken ist meiner meinung schon
ein großer fortschritt
ein fortschritt gegenüber von
indifferenz für mich ist indifferenz in
einer jugend das schlimmste was einer
jugend passieren
gleichgültigkeit mich geht's nicht an
das ohne mich nicht wahr
das ist traurig wenn eine generation
eine ganze generation der 14
dann ist etwas nicht gut daher ich bin
nicht glücklich wenn ich jetzt so viele
gibt die sich ja ja er hat recht wir
müssen uns empören
aber damit kann es nicht aufhören jetzt
muss man sagen ja war
darüber können wir vielleicht sprechen
sehr gerne
natürlich ist es aber auch interessant
noch ein halter lauf zuschauern auf ihr
leben denn sie sind ja nicht ein arsch
und provokateur ein provokateur der sein
leben als als avantgarde ist mit der
pauke traum und durch die länder zurück
und die leute zur rebellion aufheizte
sondern sie sind ein hoch dekorierter
diplomat und wie in aller welt passt
diese indikation dieser rebellion die
skandalisierung zu einem diplomaten
da muss man irgendwie einen bogen
schlagen einen weiten bogen
ich wurde gleich nach dem krieg gezogen
die französischen diplomatische karriere
aber trug schon in mir die verantwortung
von einem vorherigen kz und einen
vorherigen kriege er den krieg
schließlich als gewonnen empfand aber
doch die gefahren dieses krieges erlebt
hat also er kann jetzt diplomat werden
aber wenn seine diplomatenkarriere sich
endlich endet wenn er 65 wissen und auf
der diplomatischen karriere in den
ruhestand zurück kommt dann kommt wieder
plötzlich bei ihm das gefühl ich muss
doch jetzt noch etwas für meine alte
verantwortung tun das ist mir wirklich
so passiert ich kann zu sagen
im jahre 1981 wurde ich 65 oder 82
würdig 65 und kam auf den ruhestand
und der präsident mitterrand war so
großzügig und gütig dass er aus mir eine
norma stern de france gemacht hat das
ist ein als es ist eine ehre eine wirre
und keine funktion
ich habe keine funktion mehr aber ich
habe jetzt von ihm die würde bekommen
ich bin also noch ich stelle irgendwie
frankreich vor
und dann frage ich mich was ist denn
frankreich eigentlich was bedeutet es
für mich habe ich einen sinn für
frankreich nicht nur als ein staat nicht
nur sogar als ein volk sondern als eine
geschichte die geschichte frankreich
trägt gewissen wird die ich immer wieder
empfinde und die gerade in der
widerstand zeit besonders wichtig darum
waren weil frankreich eben keine rolle
mehr spielte sondern nur versuchte sich
weiter zu schlagen und das gelang ihm
schwer daher dieser bogen über die lange
diplomatenkarriere herüber in diesen
letzten jahren meines lebens wo ich mir
sage jetzt mal jetzt das kann ich jetzt
jetzt kann ich diese werte frankreich
irgendwie so empfinden und so vorbringen
dass sie irgendwie wichtig sind für die
jungen franzosen und vielleicht warum
nicht auch für die jungen europäer aber
etwas was man ja auch spürt sie sind
kein witz und sie sind kein orange wie
man sie gekannt hat auch in ihrer
generation
ja das ist wahrscheinlich auch was man
als diplomat zwischen endlich lernt man
lernt als diplomat zum beispiel dass
keine faire
endgültig ist man wird eine neue einen
neuen text vorbringen eine neue
institution bauen wenn man will dafür
verhandeln mit wem verhandelt man mit
seinen freunden aber auch mit den alpen
anderen kulturen
da ist gerade die erfahrung der
vereinten nationen für mich sehr wichtig
gewesen
ich habe jahrelang entweder als
internationaler oder als französischer
stellvertretern in den vereinten
nationen gehandelt
sie sehen mein deutsch ist leider etwas
wackelig man muss immer wieder geduld
mit mir haben also diese diese erfahrung
dass man zwar vorwärtskommt wir haben
schon darüber nachgedacht aber dass es
nicht durch revolte geht sondern durch
verhandlung die für das verständnis von
dem was der andere zu geben wird wo man
mit ihm sich einig sein kann
diese art und weise die weltgeschichte
anzusehen
die lernt man als ein alter diplomat
aber der moment wo passivität
inaktivität umschlägt der moment wo aus
theorie praxis wird das sind glücklich
im moment dann trotzdem sind es auch
tragische momente man hatte immer auch
das gefühl dass es die katastrophe
braucht wie der zweite weltkrieg eine
war damit sich wirklich etwas tut und
dass es nicht so sehr die institutionen
selbst sind die dank dem verstand und
der vernunft und dem guten willen der
politiker der bürger schnell vorwärts
macht und wir haben heute das gefühl
dass uns die zeit davonrennt
haben sie dieses gefühl auch
ja ich habe das gefühl dass wir großen
bedrohungen bevorstehen große gefahren
stehen heute vor uns
sie sind nicht so klar wie damals die
bedrohung eines krieges oder später die
bedrohung eines totalitären systems
dieser stalin system aber die
bedrohungen gibt es und wenn man die
irgendwie erforschen
dann kann man schon denken es ist
höchste zeit etwas dagegen zu tun
was sind diese bedrohung ich versuche in
diesem kleinen muck drei zu erklären
die erste bedrohung nicht ganz leicht zu
erfassen aber nicht gleich zu überkommen
nämlich der immer größere unterschied
zwischen den sehr sehr sehr armen und
den fürchterlichen reichen diese
diskrepanz ist ja diese diskrepanz ist
immer unerträglicher
es hat immer arme gegeben und immer
reiche gegeben aber die armen wussten
nicht so viel von den reichen und die
reichen durch zufall den abend
heutzutage mit all den neuen
instrumenten der information wissen die
armen warum sind wir denn so arm und
warum haben die anderen die möglichkeit
alles zu tun was sie wollen und wir
nicht diese entfernung von reichtum und
armut ist etwas in meiner meinung dass
wir gefährlich ist es kann so stark
werden auch wenn sie sich gegenseitig
gut kennen das dann wirklich die revolte
kommt und was ist denn der terrorismus
wenn nicht auch ein sich darauf stützen
dass einige empfinden die anderen sind
zu mächtig und zu reich und das wollen
wir nicht mehr und dagegen geht unser
hast und dann schreiben wir terror
also das ist schon wirklich eine der
großen bedrohungen
unserer zeit die zweite ist natürlich
das haben wir jetzt seit 30 jahren und
wir erfahren dass wir uns so schlecht
der erde gegenüber benommen haben der
natur gegenüber benommen haben dass wir
die erde kaputt machen und das wird
möglicherweise wenn es so weitergeht auf
der erde gar nicht mehr leben können
das ist eine enorme bedrohung wie wird
sie aber von der jugend empfunden dass
es für mich noch eine frage
es gibt zwar immer mehr grüne und ich
habe mich selbst für die französischen
grünen eingestellt aber sie sind noch
eine minderheit ist das für die jugend
heutzutage eine empörung eine bedrohung
gegen sie sich empören kann und sich
engagieren können
ich halte das für sehr möglich und sehr
wünschenswert denn die gefahr ist da
man kann schon den wissenschaftlern
recht geben die uns sagen um so
weiterzuleben in aller welt brauchen wir
vier planeten und wir haben leider nur
eine auf den mond können wir vielleicht
aber auf die sektoren bestimmt nicht
also wir müssen schon darauf achten und
das ist etwas wofür sich die jugend
wirklich einsetzen könnte und einsetzen
sollte das ist die zweite naja die
dritte ist der konflikt der kulturen
nicht wahr
wir leben in einer gemeinsamen welt wir
wissen was alles vor sich geht in allen
ländern
wir kennen auch die kulturen china in
ich nahm afrikanische kultur und wir
sagen uns wenn die gegeneinander kämpfen
einmal dann auch wieder chaos
also da braucht auch die jugend die
möglichkeit es sich um zu sehen sich den
ohr aufzumachen und die augen
aufzumachen was passiert heutzutage in
afrika in china in kairo in israel und
palästina und wie können wir dazu
beitragen dass die kulturen sich
bekämpfen sondern sich gegenseitig
irgendwie dialektisch so zu behandeln
dass sie weiter gehen zusammen mit den
grundwerten die es in allen kulturen
gibt diese grundwerte zusammen aufbauen
und nicht gegen ein für israel und
palästina zu schreiben sie auch ganz
konkret und greifen auch an in ihrem
buch haben sie eine lösung für dieses
problem
es ist für mich ein sehr nahe problem
ich war dabei 1947 48 als der staat
israel gegründet wurde und zwar wurde er
gegründet natürlich von den juden die da
waren die ich eigentlich wurden aber er
wurde gegründet von den vereinten
nationen von dem sicherheitsrat und dem
generalversammlung der uno die haben
gesagt die juden brauchen einen staat
sie haben 2000 jahre lang einen start
gehabt sie sind als von antisemiten
immer wieder angegriffen
es ist höchste zeit dass sie jetzt einen
staat bekommt und ich war dabei und habe
gesagt ja das ist richtig wir wollen ein
staat israel
haben und ich habe gesagt ja die
engländer die ja palästina besitzen
die haben natürlich auch verantwortung
den arabern gegenüber wir müssen da
verhandeln und da gab es wären dann dort
erst und der wurde dann ermordet dann
gab es wild bunch und er hat sehr gut
verhandelt gesagt gut 55 prozent für
israel 140 prozent für traktion daniel
also für die araber nie da war auch so
hat es bedeutet dass ungefähr 700.000
araber aus dem land israel heraus
mussten
das haben die dann begriffen hat ein
nachbar eine katastrophe für sie
das habe ich auch mit gefügt aber ich
dachte damals naja das kann sich schon
regeln
die arabischen länder können doch die
flüchtlinge annehmen und das 40 und
regeln und für israel ist es wichtig
dass er an land hat was groß genug ist
um sich da eine große jüdische kultur
aufzubauen hat auch ist auch geschehen
bis zum jahre 1967 dann hatten us
herzlich schlecht behandelt und die
israelis haben sich gesagt wenn wir
jetzt nicht einschlagen
dann ist eine gefahr für uns gut sie
haben eingeschlagen
aber es nicht nur haben sie diesen krieg
sehr schnell gewonnen sondern sie haben
daraus die erfahrung gezogen jetzt
gehört uns ganz palästina
wir können das alles oben sogar den sie
dari und gaza und die westbank alles
gehört uns jetzt dass es alles von uns
ist von gott uns gegeben da bleibt mir
jetzt das war entgegen internationalen
rechtes und die vereinten nationen haben
ganz richtig gesagt nein eroberung und
kolonisierung eines landes was einem
nicht gehört das geht völlig gegen
internationales recht
und sie haben resolutionen geraten
der heirat 242 3 untersagt und die
zahlen erinnere ich immer und haben
gesagt nein
die israelis müssen zurück die lösung
ist da sie haben gefragt was ist denn
die lösung
die lösung ist die palästinenser wollen
einen staat haben wir alle völker der
welt die jerusalem sei die hauptstadt
von den beiden seien und die die die
grenzen von 1968 sollen wieder
zurückkommen das ist die lösung darauf
rechne ich auch damit dass ich jetzt ein
unternehmer bin von einem tribunal und
zwar im virgin johnson und treiben das
hat man damals für vietnam aufgesetzt in
den siebziger jahren da hat man gesagt
die zivilbevölkerung die menschen die
uran kennen die diplomaten sind sollen
zusammen ein kriminal aufrichten und
sollen sagen wer ist hier der fehler und
es sind eben nicht nur die israelis sind
auch einige der palästinenser und es
sind auch die europäischen staaten und
es ist auch die uno und die usa
die sind nicht die sind zu feige um
israel dazu zu bringen endlich diese
lösung anzunehmen und wenn jetzt nicht
ein jahr nach washington sagt kommt und
sagt ja ja ich bin schon dafür dass es
einen palästinensischen staat gibt es
ist schon eindruck in der richtigen
direkt in richtung aber bisher was die
israelis zu geben wollen ist noch
ungenügend um das problem zu lösen
da muss man also noch weiter daran
arbeiten das versuche ich auch
also das heißt er spricht jemand der an
die institutionen glaubt ja der denkt
dass der weg der eingeschlagen ist
richtig ist und dass sie auch sagen das
ist eine strategie die existiert aber
sie zu begründen ist schwierig und hier
ist genau der konflikt und diesen
konflikt kann man mit reiner abhörung
nicht lösen sondern hier ist das
engagement auch die
kompromissbereitschaft wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe gefragt und hoffnung
immer wieder hoffnung ist für mich das
gegenteil von verzweiflung ich war
wir dürfen darum nicht verzweifeln wir
kennen uns selbst noch nicht genug um zu
verzweifeln wenn wir uns kennen als eine
rasse als eine spezies an ein tier das
immer nur gewalt kennt und nur egoismus
kennt wenn wir das annehmen und sagen ja
so sind wir da können wir nicht dafür
dann glaube ich irgendwie wunsch ich
glaube wir sind auch wir haben auch die
möglichkeit und dass es die hoffnung von
mir und ich denke auch von vielen
jugendlichen die dieses buch lesen
werden wir haben die hoffnung wir können
menschlich werden in dem sinn dass
menschlichkeit nicht nur egoismus
sondern auch angst ruhig und und liebe
für andere und respekt vor anderen
besitzen wir auch das müssen wir
aufbauen dann in einer gewaltlosen in
verbindung miteinander zu arbeiten so
dialektisch die verschiedenen ideologien
die sich entgegen gehen überwinden und
in einer welt herein kommen die eine
harmonische welt gesellschaft wichtig
ist das reine utopie wollte fragen ist
es naiv auch was denken sie
also ich würde sagen wir haben immer mit
utopien gelebt alle religionen sind
utopie die christliche religion sagt
einmal werden wir alle wieder erstehen
und werden im paradies zusammenleben das
ist eine völlige utopie die juden sagen
ist wird ein messias kommen und da wird
werden alle probleme der welt gelöst das
ist auch eine utopie die kommunisten
sagen wenn wir alle kommunisten werden
dann kommt ein wunderbarer welt
kommunisten staat das ist auch eine
utopie und unsere liberalen liberalen
konservativen menschen sagen wenn wir
keinen staat mehr brauchen sondern alles
nur mit entwicklung und mit immer mehr
geld und immer mehr wirtschaft und markt
das ist auch eine utopie
keine dieser utopien wird sich bewähren
wir brauchen eine andere harmonischere
utopie
dafür müssen wir auch den listen
irgendwie das reichen
und vielleicht sogar den chinesen mit
ihrem hin und jank das ist keine so so
mörderische utopie wie die religionen
die moneten die habe ich nicht gern ich
habe größte vorliebe für die
griechischen götter die sind viel acht
die der kanton mit hermes sprechen oder
mit apollo oder mit aphrodite dass es
ganz besonders schön also nicht wahr
diese einheitliche 8 zu sagen diese
ideologie ist die richtige die andere
ist die richtige das ist gefährt man
merkt dass sie das wort universell sehr
gern haben sie sie denken in diesen
dimensionen und genau hier wenn man die
welt als gesamtes nimmt und und die
komplexität ist angesprochen haben
dieser aktuellen welt
die utopie die innere aufgewühltheit die
aggression und man weiß nicht lohnt es
sich sich zu engagieren weil man sowieso
nichts ausrichten kann
von den revolutionen haben wir ein
bisschen auch respekt gewonnen oder
wissen das vielleicht eine
weltrevolution nicht das ist was wir
gerade anstreben in einem kriegerischen
sinn
der arabische frühling zeigt aber eine
auch sehr pragmatische vorgehensweise
es ist ein pazifismus ist ein wichtiges
wort sehr wichtig es ist das netzwerk
sind die medien die die verbreitung
es ist keine wirkliche führerfigur in
diesen revolutionen steckt drin und es
hat etwas sehr auch lokales und etwas
was eigentlich eine neue form von utopie
vielleicht ist eben eine pragmatische
form der utopie und die frage wenn diese
welt probleme die sie benennen
auf dieser welt ebene sehr komplex sind
ist dann die lokale initiative eine
antwort auf die globalen
herausforderungen
natürlich muss man das lokale und das
weltweite irgendwie in verbindung
bringen
wenn es ein eine weltweite vision gebe
wie es zum beispiel damals von roosevelt
wirklich eine vision mit der charta der
vereinten nationen in san francisco 1945
da steht schon eine welt vision
demokratische welt vision mit den
menschenrechten und den freiheiten den
vier freiheiten freiheit des gegen also
die vier freiheiten des atlantik das war
eine video
wir brauchen heute eine weltweite vision
aber locker
muss man daran arbeiten dass diese
vision irgendwie pragmatisch eingebaut
ist in der 8 und weise wie sich menschen
in allen verschiedenen ländern
irgendwie verhalten da ist die wirkliche
schwierigkeit ich bin natürlich und
viele meiner freunde sagen möchte immer
noch auf die vereinten nationen scharf
naja aber sind das ist das nicht
vergangenheit nicht sagen nein
für mich ist es zukünftig eine eine
allgemeine ein allgemeiner institution
wo alle völker und aller stadtstaaten
mit dabei sind und zusammen arbeiten
das brauchen wir können ohne das gar
nicht auskommen
aber es genügt nicht wir müssen auch auf
der ebene der zivilen figuren müssen wir
diesen selber billion befürworten und
dann so arbeiten dass diese welt
institution wirklich die genügende
gewalt haben
um das durchzusetzen dass menschen junge
oder ältere menschen in jedem land in
jeder region in jedem kanton der schweiz
wollen und versuchen vorwärts zu bringen
wenn jemand es nur allein in einer
kleinen gruppe tut dann hatte das gefühl
ja das ist vielleicht glücklich aber
wenn die ganzen welt anders arbeiten
dann müsste es ja nicht man muss also
schon das zusammenarbeiten irgendwie
empfinden aber man kann sagt wir fangen
das an die anderen sind noch nicht
bereit aber die kamen auch noch
deutschen das wäre für mich eine
gesinnung voller hoffnung und ich kam
wenn mein kleines buch irgendeinen
effekt haben kann und haben soll ist der
effekt hoffnung breit zu bringen
zu sagen ihr empört euch nicht um
sonst engagiert euch nicht umsonst
es kann etwas vor sich gehen heute
morgen und übermorgen was uns allen
nützlich ist das harmonisch sich aus
bildet das haben wir damals in unserer
jugend empfunden und wir haben uns
bleibt ja wenn die menschenrechte
programm werden dann wird alles gut es
ist nicht so gut bekommen
viel hat sich wieder mal schlecht
entwickelt aber die möglichkeit dieser
besseren entwicklung sie steht in ihren
in ihren herzen
wie sehen sie die entwicklung und die
bedeutung der
nichtregierungsorganisationen unter
angeles in dieser entwicklung drin denn
oft hat man auch ein bisschen das gefühl
dass sie besser funktionieren schneller
funktionieren auch einem zeitgeist
besser entsprechen weil eben der glaube
an die institutionen der
regierungsinstitutionen der jugend fehlt
und man sich dann aufgehoben fühlt und
auch aktiver fühlt in einer ngo das ist
eben für mich das interessante wo
stammen denn diese
nichtregierungsorganisationen hier
sie stammen verdikt da der vereinten
nationen
das wort nichtregierungsorganisation
wurde da gegründet die die gründe der
vereinten nationen hatten schon das
gefühl dass regierungen allein es nicht
leisten könnten und sie haben gesagt sie
müssen immer sich die mission
handeln können mit der unterstützung von
nicht regierungs organisation
das dachte man sich da holte damals
sagte man an kirchen an gewerkschaften
eine kooperative große gruppen
man sagte auch an stiftungen und so
weiter und dann hat sich immer mehr was
ganz anderes entwickelt
nichtregierungsorganisation über
menschenrechte über entwicklung hat es
immer mehr gegeben und gibt es jetzt
überall und die haben ein anrecht darauf
mit den vereinten nationen zu verhandeln
in dem in dem menschenrechtsrat in genf
dabei ergänzen sich war da ist die
richtige struktur für menschen richten
da gibt es den hochkommissar für
menschenrechte eine neue errungenschaft
seit dem jahre 1995 ist noch gar nicht
so alt dass gibt es eine figur jetzt die
kann über alle in alle länder gehen und
sagen hier vorsicht sie haben sich für
menschenrechte eingesetzt
und jetzt wird hier gefoltert was
bedeutet dass da muss ich ihnen schon zu
sagen das dach dürfen sie nicht das ist
schon ein fortschritt
und gerade diese
nichtregierungsorganisation human rights
watch amnesty alle noch andere die dazu
arbeiten die sind von der uno
aufgefangen und es ist die uno das
diesen druck auf die regierungen
übertragen kann
die regierungen die sitzen da und hören
zu und wenn die nicht
regierungsorganisationen stark genug
sind wie damals bei attac gewesen sind
in zetel und dann den porto alegre
das bedeutet eben eben ein neueres ein
neues leben der weltgesellschaft nicht
mehr
nur regierungen leider immer noch zu
viel finanz möchte aber immer mehr
nichtregierungsorganisation für
menschenrechte sie sehen die
hoffnungsvoll ich bin natürlich wird man
mir sagen jaja das ist aber alles nur
gerede
das ist alles nur eine sprache und
schrift
aber wo geht es denn irgendwie wirklich
vorwärts
na ja da muss ich und sagen meine
hoffnung ist dass das jahr 2012 das
jetzt aus bevor steht wenigstens eins
haben wird und zwar das zwanzigste die
zwanzigste konferenz.de ist vor 20
jahren nach rio und zehn jahre
johannesburg da werden noch mal alle
staaten zusammensetzen und werden sich
noch mal die frage stellen wie machen
wir die erde so dass sie uns weiter
tragen kann das doch ein richtiger große
frage
und diese große frage die kann man
beantworten indem man quasi über die
nation hinaus denkt in dem man aber auch
über die generationen hinaus denkt und
hier ist es interessant sie mit ihrer
lebenserfahrung zu sehen der die jugend
anzusprechen vermag das ist ein glück
oder eine gabe eine chance auch die
sagen wie sehen sie dieses verhältnisses
konkret zwischen den alten und den
jungen und wie soll man miteinander
sprechen also für mich ist natürlich das
schönste mit einem so jungen menschen
wie sie zu sprechen und noch darüber
hinaus mit schülern mit studenten zu
sprechen
und das kann ich ihnen sagen was sie
irgendwie interessieren kann ich kann
nicht klagen
tun sie wie ich bin jetzt ein als der
mann ich habe nicht
viel zu tun ich kann nicht mehr tun tun
aber ich kann ihnen sagen seid habt
vertrauen in euch selbst empfindet euch
fragt euch das bin ich denn das will ich
denn und dann werdet ihr vielleicht dass
er empfinden dass ich in meiner jugend
empfunden habe das ist etwas für das ich
mich einsetzen wird habe ich mich dafür
eingesetzt warum würden würdet ihr das
auch nicht heutzutage empfinden und ihr
wird euch dafür was ganz anderes
einsetzen
als was ich in meiner jugend gekannt
habe aber dass man sich einsetzen soll
sich erstmal empören sein einsetzen
das ist doch etwas was ich erfahren
haben
diese erfahrung kann ich versuchen euch
zu übertragen ich kann versuchen
aus meiner erfahrung eines sehr alten
menschen euch jungen menschen und den
ganzen generationen jetzt zusammen
nehmen
irgendwie eine hoffnung ein zuflüssen
und ein vertrauen sie sind frauen und
männer und menschen sie haben in sich
die möglichkeit gewisse probleme
bedrohungen gefahren anzuerkennen und
dann zu versuchen sie zu überwinden wenn
sie das tun da sind sie richtige frauen
und richtige männer wenn sie es nicht
tun wenn sie davon absehen wenn sie
sagen das geht mich nichts an
dann sind sie keine richtigen menschen
mehr
das ist natürlich etwas gefährlich zu
sagen denn wenn das bedeutet jetzt wenig
gleich kämpfen und will ich gleich die
waffen
dazu wird na ja da muss immer wieder die
anden warnung kommen bitte keine gewalt
bitte verhandeln bitte verstehen was der
andere will mit ihm darüber sprechen
das ist für ihn notwendig was ist für
mich notwendig wie können wir das so
zusammen bringen dass wir beide
überzählig wie er dass es einen ganzen
problem
das muss man auch lernen diese hoffnung
die sie trägt und man hat immer das
gefühl dass die zivilcourage die sie
verkörpern das sie ansteckend wirkt aber
es gibt in diesem neuen buch das im juli
erscheinen wird engagiert euch auch eine
kurze pessimistische oder ein bisschen
melancholische note wo sie auch ganz
bewusst schreiben dass es etwa zehn
prozent der menschen sind haben dieses
potenzial des engagement und das bleiben
dann immer noch 80 bis 90 prozent
passive schreiben sie für die passive
oder für die aktiven bestätigen sie
diese wenigen im bewusstsein sind
weniger oder versuchen sie die anderen
zu holen ich würde natürlich am liebsten
sagen was ich sage geht alle an
das universal bestehe immer wieder
darauf das heißt uns kaster mitgebracht
was ich wünsche was ich mir wünsche
wünsche ich mir für alle nicht nur für
die mit
erhalten sondern für die ganze völker
aber ich glaube auch dass man mehr
hoffnung hat wenn man weiß mein
engagement
ich kann nicht darauf rechnen dass mein
engagement sofort gleich 90 prozent oder
sogar 50 prozent
von allen leuten trifft im widerstand in
frankreich in den 1940 er jahren waren
es höchstens zehn prozent
die wird nicht widerstand leichte tore
in den ersten jahren und dann am ende
des krieges wurden sie plötzlich 90
prozent und ich sage mir wenn es nur
zehn prozent gibt die wirklich daran
glauben dass etwas möglich ist und sie
sich dafür engagieren für mich besser
wäre es wenn 20% und 30% werden aber
auch mit zehn prozent kann man schon
anfangen denn dass sich ausbreiten von
einer positiven idee ist etwas schloss
gerade heute in den neuen bedingungen
des miteinander sein kann man sich sagen
wenn es zehn prozent wirklich mutige
gibt dann erfahren dass die 90 anderen
prozent auch und sage ich ja warum sind
wir nicht auch und mutig dass wir schön
können wir das zusammen versuchen sehr
gerne isst dann esse ich danke ihnen
sehr sehr herzlich für dieses gespräch
gehen dann halt mich sehr gefreut